par groupes les gilet jaune s'éloigne du
parc salengro où le point de départ des
manifestations du samedi à nevers depuis
le début du mouvement et frappé d'un
arrêté d'interdiction
après quelques hésitations ses
l'esplanade du palais ducal qui sert de
lieu de rassemblement de toute manière
on n'a pas le choix c'est la loi et il
nous a interdit les gars secteur on peut
pas y aller on y borne à 135 euros
d'amendé
on n'y va pas et après on
on s'organise en il faut arrêter de
courir comme des lapins dans les rues
quelques manifestants choisissent de
rester sur place une centaine d'autres
prend la direction du pont de loire pour
renouer avec le blocage d'un rond-point
circulation filtré dans le calme jusqu'à
l'arrivée des forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
elle contrairement aux deux semaines
précédentes pas deux heures
beaucoup refusent la confrontation mais
malgré la baisse des effectifs
n'entendent pas arrêter le mouvement
monsieur mac on refuse de nous écouter
monsieur par makoun en fait qu'à sa tête
et bat nous aussi on n'en fera qu'à
notre tête on continuera le moment si on
existe on sera glisse sur les cases on
est 15 et on n'arrêtera pas tant qu'on
ne sera pas écouté quelques heures à
manifester de rue en rond point sous le
soleil de printemps en promettant déjà
de revenir samedi prochain pour un acte
vain